hi chris hi johnny how are you very well
thanks so much
cheryl thank you for speaking to us
today ah it's so good to see you
listen i know that this new song was
created during this past year and i
understand
the whole time apart has really given
you extra gratitude for being able to do
this again
and be realigned with all the joy um
but i have to ask you is there a time in
your life when you felt music
wasn't bringing you joy or has it always
been that for both of you
um you know we've had ups and downs as a
band and i suppose there was a period
maybe fairly early on in our career
where we
weren't maybe having quite as much of a
good time as we should have done
i think but that was more because of
things obscuring the music though
yes but but i think that
once we kind of got through that period
um yeah no no it's it's been music
that's given us
everything in our lives i think
absolutely chris you actually started
this song that we're talking about today
one day in your bathroom
banging on the bathroom sink i
understand are you constantly
making noise like that around the house
banging on the kitchen tables and and
the walls
yeah i should give credit where credit's
due it was not my sink
it was someone i'm not sure who sink it
was i was staying in a house
uh so i don't know who to thank
for that which plumber but it was um
async and the answer to the question is
yes i'm always making some form of noise
it's which is frustrating for people
around
i was just gonna say how's everybody in
the house with that
um uh fine
so i guess when my son's walking around
the house doing that because i'll often
say stop it you're driving
he could be the next cool place so i
need to ease up right
i would ease up yeah i would be careful
okay that's good i will do that um you
guys are so involved in making song
these
songs these days just how many voice
notes or voice recordings do you each
have on your phone
when it comes to making making music
uh i mean you have literally hundreds of
thousands i think apparently
i think i think uh as far as a great
question sure the other day
because um i do put everything on voice
notes yeah and the other day
i realized that to listen to them all
would take 15 days
no and my phone is
really always you know my phone is doing
great but it's always struggling to
handle them all so i have a very nerdy
system of
i email things to myself and it's very
complicated but there's there's lots of
them
and most of them are you know
unlistenable
except for me but do you put them in
like a special glass box with a big lock
because that's a precious phone now i
mean that's a lot of incredible material
well no the truth is it's not it's a lot
of
one-man noodling uh
in the wind and then occasionally a
great song shows up
it's all the hours of being a fisherman
where you don't catch a fish basically
okay higher power this song is such an
incredible vibe it's exactly what we
need right now it just it makes you want
to dance it makes you want to move
how much of your own lives end up being
reflected in the music that you guys are
making like higher power
i think um well we we take inspiration
from
kind of everything around us you know
but you know we had a wonderful time in
the studio with max martin and
being together being able to get
together again we felt so grateful and
happy i think we really wanted felt
freer to make more
upbeat music than we've ever made before
i think our i think our lives and our
music are com completely intertwined
and i think also the way the way we look
at other people's lives is in there too
so i think it's always a bit about us a
bit about everyone else and
a bit about where we live and a bit
about what what it's like inside
our heads or my head or so i think it's
all it's all just one big
there isn't really any separation
the the the music video when you watch
it you just feel
so good and you you all look like you're
having a good time what was it like
shooting that music video and sort of
just just putting that out there for
everybody
that's a great question sure well
actually that the video that's out right
now is really just supposed to be a
like a teaser video but it but it ended
up being better than we
better than we thought it would be so uh
that was really supposed to be a teaser
for the main video that's still not
quite finished
because there's lots of animation and
stuff so so that was just super fun we
we shot that what
a couple of weeks ago eight days before
the song came out in a
in a car park just for fun because phil
who's our fifth member and um
like oversees creative direction and
stuff he um
he had found this hologram company who
had
made holograms of these dancers that we
worked with for our
video coming up and he said look at
these holograms of the dancers
and we said oh let's just film something
in the car park and now
we're speaking to you about it that's
the reality it's a reality of
life but it's so good i think that's
i think that's maybe what you see when
you watch the video
it's the pure joy of it sometimes when
we're doing something for so long
it takes the simplicity and the joy out
of it but the music video and the whole
vibe of it is just so clean
yeah yeah that's accurate i mean we we
really
love what we do more than ever
now that it's been threatened with being
taken away really
performing so we we don't we're happy to
perform to some fake holograms in a car
park
you know right now we'll perform any
entity
we're available what what's gonna happen
when you hit the stage
i mean it's gonna i mean you do a lot of
jumping in general it's going you're
gonna explode like what
what do you anticipate that feeling
being like one day when you when you hit
that stage again with with your
with your fans i think it's gonna
i mean without trying to sound um
uh i think it's gonna be really good
chris i don't want to get too ahead of
myself
don't want to raise the bar too high
there okay i think um
i think it's what we really are you know
really gunning for and that's what it's
why we exist so it's
but we're trying not to um get too hung
up on the fact that we can't
play like that right now we're trying to
do what we can do
really well and when that comes around
it comes around otherwise we would go
mad
yeah but just to be even be able to
rehearse
together again must be a charge yeah
it's
it's brilliant to get back together and
see lots of the crew
and you know it's been really good we
played a show yesterday for one person
yes
i played a show yesterday for my singing
teacher mary she didn't like it
she didn't like it at all she never
liked it and uh
she then after she told me that i wasn't
singing the scientist very well
do you know who i am but i like that i
like that there's people in your lives
that
you know can take you to task is there
someone
that you both go to um
that can tell you no or that when you're
listening to your music back or
something you've written or worked on
that their opinion of that song is is
is is a barometer for you who's that
person
well i mean i think if if a song
gets past will the drummer
he uh he it means it's hopefully it's
good yes
uh he's he's uh he's the one that it
really has to get past
to be released isn't it yes i don't know
if you've
seen this film cheryl called the biggest
little farm have you seen that film
no i have it so it's an amazing film
about
biodynamic farming which is okay in my
opinion the best way to farm it's
allowing nature to balance itself out
and in the in the end of the movie they
show this
this sort of wheel of predators and prey
and
crops that need this and everything
balances
yeah and our band is just like that so
an occasion we have someone else come
into that wheel of balance like max
martin
but it all seems to it all seems to
level out those opinions there's enough
of a clash
and enough for harmony that if something
makes it out of that
then we we can stand behind it so i love
that
um this last year marked the 20th
anniversary of your debut
album how would you describe this next
chapter of your music
i'd say it's it's the same band but just
with much better diets
diets of what are we talking like
philosophical or
less chips more veggies like whip
exactly both those things
okay okay lots
it is true it's the same exactly the
same people but with so much
experience and openness to learning
stuff and
trying to be healthier trying to be you
know i think when you're starting a band
i'm sure it's the same when you're
starting in tv you're trying to get the
job
yeah and after a while you feel like
okay i've got this job what am i going
to do with the job
and so um that's probably the main
difference is that
we exist for a different reason right
now then we were existing more for us
right and now we existing because
we want to connect with you know lots of
people around the world
yes well you definitely do that's for
sure so there's no doubt in my mind that
this song
is you know the song on everybody's
summer playlist
do you both have a summer playlist right
now and what is at the top of that
okay good question oh
no i don't but uh
johnny say your song say yourself if you
don't have one
no um you know what i
i was just listening to
an album by the coral the new album
which is called
coral island i think and i think that
i'll probably be listening to that quite
a lot i think
yes over the summer cool okay how about
you guys
oh me i'm gonna listen i'm listening
right now i'm
listening right now to a lot of jay
baldwin
oh yeah i just watched his film the boy
from medellin
which is amazing and so any reggaeton is
what i'm into right now particularly
him that's fantastic
well thank you so much for your time
today we can't wait till you tour
in canada and we see you in toronto
we're looking forward to it
thank you cheryl i have one question for
you what what is that behind you is it
coral with ostrich feather yes thank you
for asking chris
thank you is that your own display this
is called pompous grass
it is very fuzzy if you move it or
disturb it
it does fall to the ground you can find
this at any floral shop
and it does make a beautiful decoration
it really does picking it up was
probably a mistake
it was but for you guys for cold playing
i'll go the extra mile
thank you cheryl all right well we owe
you some floral displays and thank you
for talking to us
amazing okay thanks gentlemen bye bye
you